hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
serious launches
on multibiotyper and more i'm alexis
cross of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
broker daltonix for more information
about our sponsor please visit their
website at brooker.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
ralph shafer b2b partner manager and
global product manager for the
multibiotyper at brooker deltonics
and our guest presenter marcus meyer who
will be joining us for the live q a
session at the end
is the global product manager for ir
biotyper and care consumables
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your view screen ralph you
may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for the nice
introduction i would like to welcome
everybody as well to
the webinar about the serious launches
on the maldi bio typer products
my name is ralph schaefer i'm from buca
in
germany and i'm very happy to guide you
through this
presentation as you all know the
multibiotype of solutions
are based on multi-tough mass
spectrometry systems
and pruca has introduced the microflex
ltsh and the mbt smart several years ago
meanwhile more than a decade these
instruments are used for the
identification of microorganisms
and goes beyond with antibiotics
susceptibility testing as well as you
can see on the left hand side we started
with microflex ltsh
introduced more than 10 years ago
the system was used heavily in mostly
clinical environment
and the feedback from the customers have
been oh we are running more and more
samples on this platform
can you can you increase the speed of
the system and
spruce is listening to their customers
we decided to
develop a new system the mbt smart which
was
introduced then to the market with a 200
hertz
smart beam laser to allow for higher
throughput
last year puka then has introduced a
very
new instrument the mbt serials which you
can see on the right hand side
which isn't system bringing positive
and negative iron mode into the market
to expand the research capabilities for
these kind of instruments
and as you can see here on the portfolio
there seems to be a gap
which will be closed by our new product
which we are going to launch
right now it's the serious one system
with the positive iron mode option
but featuring as well all the new
technology
all the improvements from the
multibiotype series platform
as you can see we would like to have a
very similar
design of the new platform so the series
one and the serials
are having a modern design
which has a different color coding to
differentiate these two
instruments the serious one
is then a new system which is using the
state-of-the-art technology from the
multibiotype materials
means having the high-capacity vacuum
system
as well as new electronics and all that
new features which i will describe in a
second in more detail
the serious one is a one iron mode
solution with positive ion mode which
is already known from microflex ltsh and
smart
systems since years and it can
cope with all the routine workflows
namely
microorganism identification but as well
subtyping
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
everything
can be run on that system
to easily differentiate the products
from
each other we have an inverted color
scheme
this time so that one can clearly see
there is a new
external design which is very modern
but you can differentiate it by the
different color code
the technology which is used in the
series and
the serious one systems are
based on a patented kruka
smart beam lifetime laser system which
runs with
up to 200 hertz repetition rate which
allows
the systems to cope with a high amount
of samples
as we want to ensure that the systems
are always
working with the best performance we
have integrated an
iron source cleaning which can be
started
computer controlled by the software
based on the second ir laser which heats
up the ion source
to really get rid of the impurities and
of the contamination in the iron source
and allows then to really prolong the
time between the maintenance intervals
as known from broker the systems will be
true benchtop systems with very small
footprint so that they can fit on each
bench in a lab
they have very low noise and a very low
weight with now
75 kilowatts as we are using the high
capacity vacuum system which is already
known from the mpt smart system
we have a very fast target exchange time
and we reduce the downtime after
maintenance because the instrument can
be
evacuated very very quickly of course
the multibiotype series and serious one
platform
are fully compatible with our software
which we are delivering with the mbt
to cover the different workflows namely
the mbt compass
compass ht as well as the ibd versions
of the compass software and the mbtca
which is a software for the u.s
market including the
the software of course we are offering
libraries with the contents to support
all the workflows
the high capacity vacuum system is
a key of the new platform as it has a
three times
larger pumping capacity versus compared
to the microflex lpsh
which clearly reduces the target
exchange time by at least
50 percent and it allows
then to shorten the time to result
because we have a very fast pumping so
the ready to measure time
is very very short and with a 200 hertz
repetition rate smart beam laser
of course we can ensure that the system
is really acquiring the data very
quickly
with this capacit high capacity vacuum
system
we can reduce the downtimes and minimize
then any interference in the lab
workflow
in terms of in service inter
interference or
in terms of a plant maintenance
everything will be can be done in within
one day
so that the interference in the lab
workflow
is really minimized on this table
you see now how the target exchange time
has been improved over the different
instrument platforms so in the table on
the right hand side you see the
microflex lpsh
where it takes about two and a half to
three and a half minutes
to be ready to measure after you have
introduced your
target plate with the smart we have been
already
faster so it's about two minutes but now
with the series and the serious one
we have been managed to go down to
approximately one minute
before the instrument is ready to
measure and that of course
minimizes the waiting times and it's
enabling
higher throughput of the instrument
with the new platform for serious and
serious one
we have updated the electronics and this
doesn't sound
maybe appealing to you but it has
brought
a huge huge difference into the
instrument
um because the current electronics are
really capable now to work with less
parts and less circuit boards which
allows us
to reduce the environmental footprint of
the instrument because all the new
electronic parts
are so powerful that we really minimized
the quantity of these parts and the
circuit boards
and therefore the system is now future
proof
and it's more environmentally friendly
than before
that faster target exchange was already
mentioned
and this is based as well on the updated
electronics
because this allows us to parallelize
some processes
in the in the instrument
with the update of the electronics using
less electronic
parts less circuit boards we are able to
reduce
the weight of the instruments from 99
kilograms for the mbt smart now down to
75 kilograms
for the series and the serious one
instruments
of course then it's easier to place
these instruments onto the bench as well
as to maneuver it in terms of a service
interference where the customer
where the service technician needs to
move the instruments
as you can see on the pictures of the
instruments
we have introduced an led strip into the
front of the instrument
to allow to check the system status
from the distance when you have multiple
instruments in your lab and you enter
the lab you want to see which instrument
is ready for measuring which instrument
is currently acquiring data
and in the unlikely event of any error
even that will be displayed on this led
strip
the improved usability was one of the
focus
areas uh during the development because
we have taken the feedback from our
customers very seriously
we have improved the
cover and the housing to easier
disinfect
the the surfaces so we have less
openings than before the rounded edges
and this leads then to the improved
usability
to give you an overview here on that
table about the
performance of the instruments and the
features of the instruments
i clearly would like to show you the the
benefit
of the serious platform so the series on
the right hand side
comes with a positive and negative iron
mode with the negative iron mode
increasing or expanding the capabilities
for
research work while the serious one
with its high capacity vacuum system
with a low weight and the smart beam
laser
is really the state-of-the-art
instrument
for all the workflows for all the uh
applications the customers would like to
run on it
and of course the new platform is where
the customers are currently moving into
trying to get the the state
state-of-the-art technology
and and really want to be part of this
innovation
uh which puka brings to the market
of course with the new serious platform
puka underlines its clear technology
leadership
we are well known in the market for
fast and reliable micro organism
identification
based on maldi tof technology and
we are providing the solutions now for
the clinical market for the research
market for pharma and veterinary
applications
and the multibio type of series with its
extended research capabilities with a
positive and negative iron mode
is really then the the tool
which is heavily used now in multiple
research groups
they are getting active now in
evaluating the
performance capabilities of the
instrument and they are publishing their
results
so positive and negative iron mode on
the biotyper series
is definitely for customers who would
like to do some additional research work
while the multibiotype a serious one
with its positive ion mode
with this one
polarity allows for the for all the
routine
application
but the instrument hardware of course is
only one point of the full
solution very important is of course
software and library with the content
and puka is well known
to have always updates on their
on their software and as you can see
here on that slide
in our ivd software for the clinical
markets
um we that we have a modular system
where the core software mpt compass
can be tailored according to the
customer needs
with different software modules and
features
and we have already several
modules available since since years like
a satellite software or
a satellite software module or a sepsi
typer module
for positive blood culture workflow
support as well as micro bacteria module
for optimized results when you are
dealing with mycobacteria
but we have added new features this year
for the antibiotical
susceptibility testing we have
introduced now
optional new controls positive controls
in the iuo mode we've had that since
since a while and we have now
transferred that as well into the ivd
software
but more important is the
mbt subtyping ivd module which comes now
as a new module with very comprehensive
features which i will
explain on the next slide because this
new module allows now for
subtyping capabilities in the ivd
workflow
as we are operating globally with our
ivd solutions
we are now supporting up 26 languages
meanwhile
and with this we can cover really a very
broad
area of countries to allow
the usage of the ibd system
yeah i wanted to show you the ivd
subtyping module
as this feature is closing a gap
in our so-called bologna workflow
which is a very rapid and cost effective
identification and ast workflow
from positive blood cultures and up to
now this
ibd subtyping module was missing
it allows the detection of specific
markers for different features
and the features are listed here in that
table
so for the resistance detection we can
for example differentiate
the cfia positive bacterial fragilis
from the cfia negative bacteria it is
fragile
you can see on the right hand side in
the table
that the subtypes are already identified
for the sample number
two and three we have one example of a
cfia positive and the cfi
negative and the importance is
that this additional information is
generated automatically by the software
module so there is no need to repeat
the acquisition of a spectra or to
re-measure the spectra
automatically when the when the detected
species is bacteria this fabulous
the software automatically tries to find
the subtype and then give the result
output
immediately onto the result report
besides this cfia positive negative
differentiation
we have included the detection of
a black apc expressing klebsiella
pneumonia
you can see this as well on the right
hand side in the table the sample number
five
is typed as a kpc positive one
while the sample number four is
not typed as a kpc positive one and
again this is done automatically by the
software
no additional measurement is required
besides this resistance detection
another feature is
a very accurate differentiation
of mycobacterium chimera from
microbacterium intracellular
you can see this as well on the right
hand side sample number seven and eight
they are detected as species
mycobacterium temera intracellular
crew but with this software algorithm
with the ivd
subtyping module we can differentiate
and type the microbacterium chimera
or the microbacterium intracellular and
that is again
done automatically by the software
so far we have had another
software platform which is called
compass ht where
ht is a synonym for
high throughput this software has been
used mainly
in industrial and pharmaceutical
environment and workflows so far
it is supporting the regulated
environment of the cfr 21 part 11
but we are now going to expand the
features and capabilities of that
software because
the high throughput capability is of
course of interest for every customer
and for this software which is an iuo
so for research use only software we
have added now
software functionality in providing
different modules and licenses
like for the sepsi type where we can run
positive blood culture workflows in
with our essay the sepsi typer kit
we have functionality for microbacteria
to allow an optimized identification of
microbacteria
the same is well it for filamentos fungi
and
we have implemented as well a new module
cost called fast module
which will support an iuo essay which is
coming soon
for rapid antibiotic susceptibility
testing
so these new modules are now expanding
this compass ht platform currently
used for research use only or general
purposes
um and in the very near future of course
one
one can envision that we are moving
these
software platform as well into the ivd
workflow
besides the software features it's of
course important
that you provide content with reference
libraries because
the best software algorithm needs of
course reference spectra to compare with
and you can see here on the right hand
side that over the last 10 years
fruca constantly on an annual basis
increased the content and the number of
species covered in the library
this is our ruo reference library which
is meanwhile then covering more than 3
hundred different species covering from
positive negative these and as well
filamentous fungi
and uh yeah we are constantly expanding
the content of this library
uh on an annual basis and
of course we are doing the similar for
our ibd
software so the ibd library
is now covering more than 3150 different
species
from positive negatives and yeasts are
included
and you can see on the right hand side
as well that there was a constant
upgrade of the content
over the over the last years and
we are working on this uh in the future
as well because every microorganism
can be of clinical relevance that's for
sure so therefore we are working on that
to give you some more details about the
updates
um for the reference library and the ivd
library we have now done and
comprehensive update of the
asymmetrobacter species
because customers have used since years
the multibiotype of solution for the
identification of
the netobacter species you can see it
here on some publications already in
2014
people have worked with that and over
the years
they have found out and that is
particular here on the
left hand side on the bottom you can see
in 2018
a group in czech republic have found out
that there are some limitations
in our library and of course they have
got in contact with us
and ask for an improvement of the
library and
as we are using our good contact to the
customer
to to really improve our solutions
um we ask them the group in in czech
republic to provide us with some asylum
bacter strains
we received 350 in 2019
we have evaluated them restraints and
169 out of them have been taken for our
library improvement
to cover than an additional 22
new cinematobacter species which you can
see on the left hand side in this
dendokram overview we have now different
strains there
to identify the species and now they are
added to the new library
to overcome the limitations which have
been detected in the past
the libraries contain as well some
yeasts and
the yeast nomenclature update uh
was really necessary this time so
from the 200 more than 200 yeast species
which we have in our libraries
103 have received a nomenclature update
and you can see in the detail 81 species
have been transferred into a new genus
21 transferred into neutrinos and new
species
and one species was transferred to a new
species in an existing genus
as well as 32 species of rich indus
candida
have been renamed to a neutrino and
yeah this is a major change of the
nomenclature
but we have got evidence from a
specialist
from the german strain collection which
you can see on the right hand side
they confirmed that this
reclassification of the yeast names and
the
change of the nomenclature was very
necessary
and it's well appreciated by the experts
so
um we are happy that we have done this
work
to really provide you with the with the
best
content in our library
some of you might know that we have of
course an fda
clearance of our multibiotyper solutions
and we call it mbtca
for clinical application in the us and
in puerto rico and this dedicated
library
have had covered
several species in the past and with the
addition of 364 new reference entries
we will be now able to cover then in
this
fda cleared version 491
species or groups we have added 59 new
species which are listed here on the
left hand side
and as well there was a renaming of 31
existing species and groups necessary
and
you might know that that we
differentiate the different versions of
the ca library by
by claims which we have sent to the fda
and get them the clearance from them
so claim 4 was the current 2019
library and the claim 6 is now the
library 2020
and you can see always the the different
names now of the
organisms in the indie library
i would like to point your attention to
this elizabeth
kenya group which was named as a group
in the claim
iv and is in the claim six in the new
library now
uh split it up into multiple elizabeth
kenya species
and um this is something which is which
is really a huge step forward
we have now this three different species
of elizabeth kenya in the library
with the 31 strains we are covering the
intra-species diversity and
we can now differentiate uh three
different species of the elizabeth kenya
and uh very important is that we can
detect now and differentiate the
anopheles
elizabeth kenya anopheles because this
is clinically most relevant species as
you can see in the in the two
examples of publications where customers
have identified
these uh organism as having a
significant
infection contribution as well as a high
mortal mortality rate and you can see
here in the dendrogram again
that we have a cluster now of these
three different
elizabeth kenya species in the library
yeah if we take a look to that organism
here
this is wolfhatimonas shitimiklastica
it was published already in 2008
and it was isolated from a fly and some
of you might think maya that is very
exotic why is puka dealing with that
but it has found out that in 2009
already first clinical cases have been
reported
and we have taken then this organism
into our io library already in 2010
and you can see on the right hand side
there have been lots of publication made
lots of
uh peer-reviewed journals have had some
some publications about it
and it was always or more and more
related into clinical case
as well so therefore we have decided now
to take this wool fatimona's chitini
classica
as well into the fda cleared
library for 2020 although it looks a
little bit exotic
every organism counts every organism can
be
of clinical relevance and therefore we
are very happy
that we can provide these organisms
even though they are a little bit exotic
into into our libraries
as a summary yeah
the multi biotyper solutions
have got a new member the serious one
with a serious one iron mode solution
for the microbiology
software features allow us to complement
our bologna workflow the identification
and detection of susceptibility in the
positive blood culture workflows with
the mpt subtyping ivd module
and of course the extensive annual
library updates and software updates
really should show you that every
microorganism
is of importance and that [ __ ] really
wants to offer the best solution
onto the market for our customers
with this i'm close to the end of this
presentation
i would like to bring your attention to
the upcoming webinars
which are taking place every tuesday on
the next three weeks
yeah please don't forget to register
there
and if you have missed some of our
already
presented webinars you can watch on
demand
they are shown here on the left hand
side
and yeah with this i would like to
thank you for your attention i
hope that this presentation was helpful
to get an overview
uh on the latest launches of of pooka
and i'm very happy now to take your
questions
thank you very much for your attention
thank you ralph for that informative
presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started and we do want to
welcome marcus back thank you so much
for
uh for being there with us through our
presentation so marcus our first
question
um is going to be how to get access
how do we get access to the library
update
yeah first of all hello everybody um
yeah that's that's quite simple that's
the usual way how
bruca is doing this so there are two
different ways
so we have an a download option that can
be used
but we are still going also for for dvd
versions
to distribute those libraries that will
be
the same process as we use since
sometime for our library updates
perfect now marcus our next question
when will the serious one be ready for
shipping
yeah a good question very important
question of course um
and uh happy to see that the interest is
there
from the audience um yeah so we are
we are in the last steps of this process
and we can definitely say that we
that we can ship first instruments this
year so this means 2020
so everything is ready and we have
instruments on stock
and only final final things to be done
like um the final steps for
documentation but we can ship
this year so that's that's for sure
wonderful news now here we
we do have another question from the
audience in regards to going back to the
library again
so is the library creation process still
the same
on the sirius and series one
yeah that's that's exactly the same so
this is i think
one of our basic concepts how we create
labor
libraries the msp concept that is one
principle of luca
and we are staying of course with this
principle and
and doing the same with serious and
serious one
and in addition as you have seen the
presentation
all the the software and libraries
there's a full
compatibility between libraries
if it's an older instrument that we have
or if it's a serious
generation of instruments that's that
stays the same so no change in this
principle
perfect now moving on to our next
question
what would be the typical application
for the negative ion mode
on the bmt series
yeah also very um very good question and
very interesting question because we are
i must say uh in in the process of
exploring and discovering more for the
or the negative iron mode on the series
so
um at the moment it's um all around
what we think what is interesting for
the community is to use the
negative iron mode for for some kind of
lipid analysis
and they are of course it comes
immediately to our mind and
what we have as a customer maybe have
seen in
several publications that we are trying
to get
more applications and solutions
for our customers for resistance testing
and that could be one possibility um as
you have seen maybe in publications the
cholesteen resistance is a
is a hot topic especially in several
countries in europe in southern europe
so that could be one of the applications
we are we are going for
um with the series one and the series
one on it
for you to keep it in mind with the
negative iron mode this is
still in the the research
mode so it's it's not in the ivd mode
it's in the research mode so gives you
more
research capabilities and especially for
for the lipid
lipid area of molecules i would say
wonderful thank you for that
clarification marcus so moving on to our
next question
how long is the lifespan of the serious
one
so if so we have a general general
policy
at broker so this means our instruments
have a lifespan or a lifetime of
of at least seven years so this is what
we
guarantee so from last production or
last
shipment to customers we are supporting
instruments then for full seven years
this is guaranteed that the policy that
we are doing we do the same
for smart and ltsh so that's the same
kind of policy
seven years in several cases of course
we
we can also support for a longer time
but this is the seven years is our
yeah let's say the policy and the state
of the art how we
how we do this
now how about this question how does the
serious
how does sirius affect the research as
compared to
recent instruments
can you please repeat sure absolutely
so how would sirius affect the research
as compared to recent
instruments
the research compared to the recent
instruments
um i'm not sure if i got the
question completely um i think for the
research it's
it's of course gives you much more
flexibility and a kind of future proof
uh of this instrument so especially with
the negative iron mode that that opens
up a complete new
window of applications especially for in
the lipid range
what i've already explained a little bit
and the the additional thing is of
course that you have a kind of future
proof
because the instrument is now really in
a completely new
uh electronics and gives you yeah a kind
of future proof
for for your research and also for your
your routine applications for both of
these
sites hopefully this is um
yeah answering the question i was not
completely sure
well thank you so much for that and to
our audience member who did put that
question and if there was some a little
bit more clarification that you're
looking for
please feel free to submit another
question and go ahead and continue
asking us
okay so marcus
does broker offer any additional
libraries besides the ones
mentioned in the presentation
yeah of course we have as an addition to
our i would say basic libraries ibd and
rule
we have a specific library because
also the the applications are of course
a little bit specific
for filamentous fungi and we have a
library a specific library that is also
combined or we recommend to use it with
a specific module that's a mycobacterial
library
and we have for some special very
highly pathogenic security relevant
organisms we have also a special library
for research use only but also for ibd
so these are the the extra libraries
that we offer and
we maintain these libraries of course
and update them on a regular basis
wonderful so we do have time for a few
more questions but i do want to remind
our audience
that those questions we are unable to
answer today and those that you submit
during the on-demand period as well
will all be answered by the speaker via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
so marcus let's continue on to our next
question
does the launching of the sirius 1 mean
discontinuation of the lt sh and
smart systems
no no this is this is not the message
here so these instruments
will will still be kept alive
you can imagine that of course many
people and customers will go definitely
for the for the next for the new
platform for serious
but at the moment we we keep the other
other instruments alive
what is also the background here we are
if we speak about the
or discuss the global registrations for
ibd instruments and applications uh this
is of course also one reason why we keep
these instruments
in our portfolio at the moment
great so moving on
can you describe the support strategy
for microflex
ltsh and mbt smart
yeah it's it's a little bit like what i
am what i mentioned before
and answered in one of his questions um
according to our policy it's uh that
we're supporting
these instruments for full seven years
after production has been stopped so
this is this is our
yeah this is what we guarantee to our
customers and
which does mean that in several cases we
um
yeah we we might support longer about
seven years is the guaranteed time that
we
support these instruments and this is of
course true for
ltsh and and mpt smart
okay and our next question so
when is the serious and the serious one
available
yes sirius sirius is available as
several
of the people from the audience might
know uh
since approximately one year so sirius
is an
instrument that we have in our portfolio
already since sometime
and serious one will be will be ready as
i mentioned
by by the end of this year so 2020
clearly as a shipping
that we can do
wonderful okay marcus so let's continue
on
and look for our next question we want
to thank the audience we have gotten
so many questions today and these are
just wonderful so thank you so much
we are going to try to get to as many as
we possibly can
um so let's
look for another one
[Music]
what about
okay here's one
is the um is it h is the hd compatible
with
ivd uh the ht is at the moment
uh compatible with our
rdp versions it's
particular first launched for for the
more for the regulated market in pharma
but we are working of course on
ht ibd versions that will come out
in the next year for sure
okay and now our next question
about maintenance time saving about how
much time can we save with sirius
yeah you have seen this um i think on
one of these slides
uh the real time from um starting or
um putting the the multi target into the
instrument
uh to the time point when we can really
start the run
and that's that's for the serious around
one minute
and for the 80 ltsh it's yeah it's
around
two to three minutes and and that's
that's i think really a difference
because you're sitting in front of the
instruments and
waiting and this time is really um yeah
minimized the waiting time so
down to one minute with the serious
platform
due to these this new vacuum system
and also for the series from the series
compared to the smart
due to the new electronics so that's
really advantage
for the customer for time to result
now um one of our audience members would
just like to
like declare clarify something with you
so
with the lifespan is it seven years
after the the discontinuation of the of
one instrument or is it seven years
after the purchase of an instrument
uh according to our definition it's um
seven years after the last purchase
of an instrument that's the definition
okay perfect thank you so much for that
clarification
so let's find a couple more questions
for you marcus
um and then just a reminder to our
audience any questions we don't have
time for today will be answered via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
so mark is our next question is broker
planning to have
filamentous fungi ivd module
and library
yeah again very good question yes you
can imagine
because we are for all the modules
libraries and software that we normally
have on on the mpt
we tend to have research use only and
general purpose version and ivd so this
means
for the filamentous fungi so this is not
the case at the moment that we had ivd
but of course
you can imagine that brooker is thinking
about this
but i cannot give you a detailed
yeah time time point or whatever now
but this is of course in our mind
now can you explain the fast testing
capability and protocol
sorry please please repeat the last
question absolutely
absolutely can you explain the fast
testing capability and protocol
ah okay so this this was of one one of
the slides as a kind of
little announcement or going to the
future
development so this will be an
application
that is dealing with antimicrobial
susceptibility testing but
for now i this is really in the
development phase so i cannot tell you
here
very shortly uh many details about this
but it will be for sure something that
is
linked to doing these ast testing
directly with mali you can imagine and
uh we are working on this so and we will
have software for this
and and so on but further details i
cannot explain here in
in detail really
wow that's perfect marcus thank you so
much
okay um so we've got time for just a
couple more questions
so here's here's our next one
time to result is mainly dependent on
data calculation
less dependent on time to start of
analysis how
fast will this be with the serious one
as
compared to smart
so the the comparison to the
to the smart system is mainly the um the
faster instrument and the docking and
everything so the waiting time is
minimized the
the biggest advantage in processing
uh will come for will come with the hd
version so that's that's more
also a combination of the computer
hardware and software
and this is the main advantage in terms
of speech
i cannot give you a concrete number here
if it's
i think it's something like a double or
triple
of the time for analysis that can be
saved but something in that range
but it's mainly due to the combination
of software and hardware
with the hd software
wonderful okay
marcus let's look for another
one more question for you
again we want to thank our audience
we've gotten so many questions
and so many great questions in so thank
you so much for all of these
okay
so now what's the difference uh once a
what's the difference bt positive and
negative ion mode
in terms of mass spectrometry
in terms of mass spectrometry i think
you know most of the
of the peptides showed for the multi
process with the maldi matrix
a positive um a positive charge
some of molly some molecules like for
instance the lipids
with the right metrics are negatively
charged and therefore there's
there's a difference in the in the
so-called iron
modes that can be used with the
instruments so that's that's the main
difference
and of course for the mass spectrometry
this means also
a slight mass difference of of two units
so that's from the mass spectrometry
part but
uh you have to make it really simple and
for
connected to the applications it's
that it's the case that different
molecule classes
uh can be measured with different modes
in the mali while the ms instrument so
therefore
lipids the negative ion mode more or
less and
peptides proteins more than with the
positive iron mode
perfect and now um
our next question is the serious
instrument
fda cleared for north america
yes sirius is
is cleared for north america not a
serious one
one we are not there
perfect thank you so much for that
clarification
so we before we go i'd like to thank the
audience audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again
thank ralph and marcus for their time
today and their important research
we would also like to thank labberts and
our sponsor brooker deltonix
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand labs
will alert you via email
for when it's available for replay
please join us next week for part 4 of
our webinar series
evaluation of the micronaut s anaerobes
mic
broth micro dilution panels with a large
collection of clinical samples
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
and until next time bye bye everyone
bye bye thank you for the questions